è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi andiamo
avanti con auto perfetto ragazzi già
messo mezz'ora ad arrivare con lane
valsa la pena perché è un gran bel posto
è indeciso tra questo lemma ma qui ci
sono sti rumori che ti rassicura non la
giornata in una maniera incredibile una
mano a scappare da quel plesso jack che
cosa fa
ma si sa systems masturbando su un
cadavere ma che schifo amico mio ma che
cazzo questo lo devo riprendere poi se
ti tango su facebook sono cazzi tuoi
questa è la cosa più disgustosa che io
abbia mai visto in un videogioco in
tutta la mia vita ve lo giuro
chi cazzo sei tu ragazzo è gente che
cammina h caso di sopra sentite alla new
york ok
lasciamo perdere ragazzi cè un team che
si sta formando sul cadavere alla donna
che è un altro pò chiamo l'elettricista
se non ci muoviamo dico perché non è
possibile tirare una cazzo di leva una
lega dove cazzo andato tizio è qualcuno
ha ritirato sulla leva cosa molto molto
interessante ci può passare no non si
può poi è allora che cazzo devo fare e
allora è stato quello stronzo a
ritirarla sulla leva ma [__]
allora di vista le superiori
guardi a [__] non ti puoi masturbare si
dimetta non ti puoi masturbare su di me
vai via via dei [__] viaggiano
togliti prega primadonna quanto sei
bello qualcosa mi dice che vuoi
prendermi a pugni ma giusto
presentimento ragazzi [__] ex un
ragazzo aiuto un pervertito mi sta
seguendo maledizione chiudi cazzo sì sì
sì ok regalo io sono perso 14 anni di
vita basta non ne posso tratto ragazzi
sono davvero prima c'è veramente sono
dove è passato col pizzo con la mannaia
prima bellissimo tiro morire
io non so dove quel tizio ma la cosa non
mi piace per niente di via dico prima
che succeda qualcosa di bruttissimo i
ragazzi sono rimasto scioccato da ancora
lotti [__] però hai rotto i [__]
lo escludo ha lanciato un morto a caso è
grazie mille però non lo prendo che
grazie comunque grazie mille e rai
ragazzi sono gentile alla fine ragazze
che lo consento però ne faccio a meno di
sesto posto dice che bello ragazze e una
scala a chiocciola stato non ci arrivo
posso farmi saltare tipo
ok ragazzi io non so che cazzo e sto
posto ma non importa ormai siamo qua
sopra quindi il real restiamo c
almeno passo per avrebbe sarà anti
stupratori forze e non so che cosa si
fanno risolto cos'è noi siamo qua non
c'è sticazzi e chi cazzo sono superman
si paga ma come faccio a nome non ce la
farò mai
si prega non so non so come non so
cosima tirati con tirati su tira stesso
marchio uomo se è uomo sei
ma che uomo sei non sarà anche tirati su
che sono vivo non ci credo
sono vivo sono caduto da 45 metri
l'altezza sono vivo perfetto non so se è
normale tutto questo ma va bene così io
credo sempre di più nei super poteri di
quest'uomo sempre facce servivo che sono
caduto da non lo sa neanche superman si
sarebbe salvato veramente che che parla
non ho bisogno di una sorella non si
abbastanza grande preoccuparti di quello
che cast salve senta lei e che cazzo ci
fa con ragazzi io gli ormai ho smesso di
farmi domande vado avanti per
disperazione praticamente perché
che cazzo è solamente marega sento sento
rumori che non mi piacciono per niente
poi non ditemi che non devo avere foto
salve
lei è molto bello amico mio senso sembra
lex luthor vado via perché è molto gravi
che te l'ho visto simpatico però non lo
so io io vado avanti ok grazie mille
comunque molto gentile
l'accoglienza ragazzi di questi tempi è
bellissima che poi senti chi cazzo sei
tu se cifre se ci prendono ci daranno
impasta lui l'uomo di sotto quell'uomo
davvero cattivo davvero davvero cattivo
dio
oddio sì ma io ti darei un po in pasto a
un microonde perché la tua testa sembra
una patata
ma tanto somiglia ad un mio amico quando
si sveglia la mattina ed è bellissimo di
qua a siliqua perfetti ci siamo noi io
non so dove sto andando non sto andando
avanti chi si è chiusa la porta in
faccia non mi stai seguendo con una
mannaia porca [__] non è fottutamente
possibile che dei tizi mi seguono con
delle mannaie una cosa che non capisco
anche il cazzo ciò scritto uccidete in
faccia fatemi capire di ricarica di qua
carica mica mi dica che ci ha fatto anni
che ce la faccio camicia faccio camicia
faccio carica già faccio kamikaze
lavaggio rica calmi se di qua roccia
emersi si dovevano me ne frega un cazzo
via dove sto andando
eccolo eccolo qui perfetto sono sono
scappati una maniera
ecco la sposa signor bruschino ecco la
sua sposa ma quale sposa che cazzo 10
cosa stanno facendo un matrimonio di qua
io non li capisco quando parlano perché
per non dispose la gente malata ragazzo
sia ragazzi questa è la mia classe
quando la lasciamo in disordine uguale
caso l urto che cosa cazzo è questo che
vi sono per sempre felici e contenti io
veramente più vario modo avanti sto
gioco più non ho parole perché c'è un
tizio che corre a caso com'è andata
qualche parte non è sparito cazzo di qua
hai rotto il cazzo però ai lotto ma
quanto sei bello chiesto il pizzo rega
chi cazzo è sto tizio io non ho idea di
chi fosse ma era veramente un figo della
madonna è spaventata mi dispiace tanto
non volevano amico video non so se te ne
sei accorto ma io ho un pene sono un
maschio ok è una cosa non devi più
essere solo non hai capito un cazzo
yo yo ma perché non mi sta seguendo non
mi vede ceco non un cazzo cioè che c'è
una sega ragazzi di vista mi sta vedendo
ma perché mi sto seguendo ci pensa pensa
che io sia la sua ragazza
amico mio io non vado con gli uomini
grazie mille lo stesso devo andare i
quadri con un sogno ma ve la portate a
labbra cazzo chiude ok non mi ha visto
io vado avanti perché noi lo po paura
che se ne esca male prima o poi quando
ero solo un ragazzino mia mamma ripeteva
se ti sposerai felice sarai alla ricerca
son destinato fin che quella giusta non
avrò trovato la finissimi fare frasi
prima
ok come non detto ok stavo scherzando
stavo cosa bella lega che fa e fa le
cose in rima è stupendo salvataggio no
no no no no no no no no no non apri apri
porta [__] ai notebook a ciò che
vorremmo so dove andare quello il
problema
ragazzi che è l'app si si si come cazzo
vado non c'è un ascensore non si va di
qua porca [__] affanculo salto al
micam l'ho vista
ragazzi non avevo visto la sca e vabbè
ma che scala di merda e fai che cazzo
con il sì vabbè ma quello io sono qui io
sono l'uomo che cadde da qualsiasi cosa
oddio stai bene
porca [__] scusa non me n'ero accorto
italia così male se senti perché poi si
na cosa del genere a te stessa sono un
maschio porca [__] sono maschio
maschio mi vedi preferiresti morire
storia che stare con me bene io ci sei
arrivato all'ora mori allora monista
sega io me ne vado via di cui però che
mi raggiunge ragazzi dove devo andare
che cazzo faccia alzando l'ascensore mi
vuole schiacciare partecipato di qualche
altro partner
sì perché pensa che io non è scaduta mi
sto stupido
cos'hai allora continuiamo il lavoro di
una donna non è mai completo hamas topic
cazzo non posso più correa [__] no
no no no no non mi dire che è di chi
adesso devo scappare la polizia mentre
l'inter zoppica non è illegale come
cannes dove domanda no no no no ragazzi
non regga vi prego non aprì al the ships
c'è un norma c'era un armadietto c'era
un [__] armadietto vicino riesco a il
profumo del mio amore tesoro non puoi
nasconderti da me cosa fa ma allora sei
diventata come un regalo per me una
delicatezza amico via con fra un paio di
occhiali da sole ma belli deve essere
scartate scassata ancora e assaporata
perché ci sono dei pervertiti sto cazzo
di gioco
io sono un maschio sono marcio the day
basti così su una barba così c'è un
pezzo
sono stato un po volgare lo so e voglio
dire che mi dispiace lo sai come diventa
un uomo quando vuole conoscere una donna
dove è una cosa non console mancanza di
tetta mi come mancanza di tette ma dopo
la cerimonia quando ti avrò preso una
donna onesta
prometto che sono un nuovo diverso io
non so però devo veramente ho finito le
parole per descrivere quello che cazzo
sta succedendo ma anche solo premesse
nell'analogo del dottore dell'altro
outlast ma mi fai paura ti senti parlami
conto
per favore vogliono mia una famiglia una
discendenza mi chiama ti tagliassero il
prezzo che ti ritrovi devi aspettare qui
so che si impaziente come messisi di
consumare il nostro amore ma cerchia di
assaporarne l'anticipazione amica mia se
tu mi tocchi con una mano io ti trancio
le palle ecco tesoro questo ti aiuterà
rilassarti che cazzo mi e spruzzato
scorregge complessate non lo so va bene
io non ho parola ragazzi che cazzo
succede mia mi ha fatto svenire 12 ore
dopo
sai che c'è kim sinclair bellissimo 12
ore dopo mi sono risvegliato dove salve
io io io sono un uomo nel caso tu abbia
dei dubbi bisogno che sanguini di me non
so che gentil sesso sopporta le stesse
ferite con più sofferenza devi davvero
fare uno sforzo stai scherzando vero
regala lega cosa sta facendo no no
ok allora quell'uomo forse aveva un pene
una volta si va beh ma regalo ma bel
bello che devo guardare perché non posso
tirarmi coprite allo schermo per favore
non posso non guardare non mi dispiace
tesoro l'amore non è per tutti
ok puoi fare il suo discorso anche a me
senza il coltello però che doveva
portato non so sto bene io vengo io
svengo accattato c'è ancora la gamba che
topico visa quindi è un problema ma non
importa ora la parte più delicata
no regate no reagan o no non posso
guardare ste cose mi fanno mi fa schifo
liga mi fa schifo che ha lo posso
guardare sta merda mentre va in onda non
ne vale neanche la pena di cosiddetti
finiamola qua tipo di merda rega che
schifo si vabbè dai capito no no no no
no no voi non avete capito un cazzo voi
non avete capito nono adesso tu mi
sleghi adesso tu mi sveglio ti costringo
guardare peppa pig per dieci ore non mi
toccare che son cazzi tuoi uno stupendo
struttura ossea e una pelle così soffice
sarei così bella io ho un pene non è
piacevole lo so ma cerca solo di
sopportarlo per me per i nostri figli
spiega che cazzo sta dicendo è una cosa
io non so chi cazzo sei non sei brutto
non ci vorrà molto fan qualche taglio
qui e qui tagliare tutto quello che è
volgare un luogo soffice per il mio seme
per formare una famiglia ragazzi che
aiuti ma perché ci sono i pervertiti
ma perché sei un pervertito di merda
perché decisione farà male il
concepimento e il parto non è mai facile
prega la ragazza ha attivato una lama ha
attivato una lama e non mi piace farò un
taglio veloce chiudi gli occhi e pensa
ai nostri figli regala quattro ragazzi
direi che possono chiudere qui per
questo episodio come al solito ragazzi
se il video è piaciuto lasciato momento
mi piace anche al pari facebook come
ogni video trovate nella descrizione
assenze da vari siti iscrivetevi noi ci
rivediamo il prossimo video belle
ragazze
[Musica]